addressing turbine tension for the first
time the Prime Minister didn't speak to
new legal action taken by the Ukrainian
World Congress against the government
but he did defend his choice those
sanctions are aimed not at our allies
but at Putin and his cronies and that's
exactly why we took this difficult
decision
to be there for our allies we're very
grateful to Canada Germany's ambassador
to Canada tells Global News it wasn't an
Ask taken lightly and acknowledges
there's no guarantee Russia won't just
turn off the Taps anyway we don't know
we simply do not know and that's I think
a very important Point Wednesday morning
Russian state-owned gazprom tweeted it
had no documents showing Siemens could
get the turbine out of Canada we do not
want to give Russia in Putin the kind of
excuse to say oh you brought it upon
yourself that we will not honor Our
obligation to deliver gas anymore
because you do not deliver the turbine
the new legal challenge against the
Canadian government calls Russia's claim
to need that turbine a disingenuous Ploy
the application for judicial review
challenges the reasonableness of The
Minister's decision to allow for the
exemption
we really should be shaken by that
reaction orobron says zelenski's Fierce
rebuke of Canada is evidence of enormous
frustration in reaction to a
precedent-setting move this is a very
unfortunate crack
in what should have been a unified
system of keeping pressure up on Russia
Russia tested us
and we failed a complicated situation
with diplomacy energy and War all on the
line Abigail Beeman Global News
Ottawa